come with me on a little walk let's
let's pontificate for a moment uh
on the desire
for poetic absolution
on the desire
for that which takes our breath away on
the desire for another world one that
radiates with Wonder and awe
now
I'm a lover of poetry I'm a lover of
literature I'm a lover of Plato's realm
of ideals I'm a lover of aesthetic
ecstasy and aesthetic Rhapsody and I
have always felt that great poetry hints
at a deeper Truth at a truth of a deeper
sort beyond the literal grid this is the
realm of music it is the realm of
Storytelling it is the realm of
Enchantment it is the realm of Fantasia
make believe I'm everywhere hidden in
the lines
there upon the pages is The Never Ending
Story So friends when I speak
about a truth beyond the literal grid
when Werner Herzog speaks about ecstatic
truth
when artists and Poets will themselves
into states of exaltation they find a
holy Madness
I want Madness I want to be shaken wrote
Sam Keane I want to be overwhelmed I
want to be overcome I want to be
subsumed I want to stop trying to make
art I want to become art I want to
become Jazz I want to merge with the
lyrics of this song I want to summon
coherence and the bardos between one
statement and another I went to God just
to see and I was looking at me whereas
once I was blind now I can see I have
turned
my passing illuminations into abiding
lights
but see it doesn't end here friends for
this is only the beginning that moment
of visionary understanding that moment
of apprehension what the Greeks call
catalepsis the truth from which nothing
can dislodge us it is not just a
transient moment of extaculation it
opens the door it rolls the red carpet
it shows you a world of possibility a
universe of possibility gray is infused
by color the invisible revealed the
mundane Blown Away by awe so take away
this message this affirmation this
exclamation it doesn't end after the
mystical experience it doesn't end after
the peak experience
it doesn't end
in that transitory Enchanted moment
where you are compelled into aesthetic
contemplation and you are face to face
with something can measure it to your
capacity for Wonder
it doesn't end there
it is only the beginning it is the
intimation
it is everything and everywhere it is
going like this come with me and you'll
see it's a world of Pure Imagination
[Music]
oh
my God
there it is bro smile at the sun
smile at the Sun
make believe I'm everywhere
Rhymes that keep their secrets will
unfold behind the clouds
and there upon a rainbow is the answer
to a Never Ending Story to a Never
Ending Story to a never
Ending Story
to whenever
Ending Story
never life there is more